amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous
regardez maintenant l'émission qui
revient avec plaisir et avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui avec moi sur ce plateau un
casting 5 étoiles ils sont très
intelligents ils ont l'oeil vif et le
cuir épais ils n'ont pas peur du débat
je vous présente mes invités le
redoutable Jean-Luc Manoël bonjour
bonjour conseiller en communication
fondateur du cabinet on y conseille à
côté de vous Roselyne Bachelot bonjour
mais cinq étoiles on est que 4 c'est
vous vous comptez dans les étoiles
ancienne ministre vous publiez 682 jours
aux éditions plomb livre dans lequel
vous racontez de façon truculente vos
682 jours au ministère de la Culture
sous Emmanuel Macron salut également
le câble c'est formidable il faut
l'acheter il faut le lire et le relire
ça va Valérie merci oui ça va très bien
de HK stratégie et Claude veille
journaliste et écrivain merci d'être sur
cette nature presque plus je viens dans
la vie plus je suis plus une âme
sensible dans cette émission on se
demandera jusqu'à quand Joe Biden 80 ans
peut encore repousser son départ à la
retraite on verra jusqu'où et Isabelle
borne est prête à aller pour faire
passer sa réforme ça nous amènera sans
transition à nous demander s'il faut
supprimer le poste de Premier ministre
pour sauver la 5e République et puis et
puis on se rendra au Royaume-Uni où les
Britanniques marquent les trois ans du
brexit par des grèves historiques mais
d'abord la tournée européenne de voler
des mires Zelinski pour la deuxième fois
depuis l'invasion russe le président
ukrainien a quitté son pays direction
Londres puis Paris puis Bruxelles
l'occasion notamment pour lui de
demander des avions de combat à écouter
nous avons besoin d'artillerie de
munitions de chars modernes de missiles
à longue portée d'avion de chasse
moderne merci de nous offrir le soutien
militaire que vous nous offrez merci
d'en faire davantage nous devons aller
plus vite que notre agresseur
doivent envisager rapidement comme
prochaine étape de fournir des systèmes
à longue portée et les jets dont vous
avez besoin pour protéger la liberté que
trop de gens tiennent pour acquises
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que cette semaine on a fait un
pas vers la guerre
notre guerre à nous non
pas je crois qu'on est toujours dans une
stratégie d'intensification du soutien à
l'Ukraine parce que l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est déjà d'empêcher que le
GRAINE ne soit vaincu militairement on
va probablement vers une offensive
massive de la Russie et il est essentiel
pour le combat que nous menons par
procuration je dirais du combat pour la
liberté le combat pour le droit
élémentaire d'un peuple à disposer de
lui-même que que
l'Ukraine soit mise en situation de
résister de tenir bon et d'infliger une
nouvelle défaite à la Russie mais encore
faut-il entendre bien ce qu'on entend
par défaite tout le monde sait bien
que la Russie ne sera pas écrasée tout
le monde sait bien que les chats
Ukrainiens défileront pas sur la Place
Rouge la défaite de la Russie c'est
l'incapacité où elle est de vaincre le
seul fait que la Russie est échouée dans
sa tentative de renverser un régime un
démocratique d'occuper un pays étranger
c'est déjà un échec cet échec là il est
essentiel que des démocraties sortent à
l'Ukraine de contenir la puissance russe
mais mais mais mais c'est une chose qui
va durer et qui est compliquée cette
semaine oui Rosine
que Claude en disant qu'il y a pas une
intensification de la guerre on sent
bien que actuellement on avait pensé la
victoire ukrainienne
allait s'avancer comme cela et on voit
bien que la situation s'est restabilisée
sans doute un peu en faveur de la Russie
a décidé massivement dans la nuit de
jeudi de vendredi d'attaquer avec
des missiles de croisière avec des
missiles solaires avec des drones les
installations électriques de l'Ukraine
elle est décidée à à casser le moral des
Ukrainiens il n'y a pas seulement une
affaire de destruction des installations
mais de destruction on est dans le froid
qui est le froid de la vraiment de
l'Europe centrale terrible de décider le
casser le moral des Ukrainiens c'est
aussi pour ça que volody mirzelinski
ça nous place comme alliés
de notre guerre ce n'est pas notre
guerre c'est la guerre de l'Ukraine et
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron a tout de
suite hier
vous n'allez pas à donner les médias
d'avion de combat cette tournée de
volodières en Europe ça nous place quand
même comme un allié indéfectible c'est
ce que j'entends moi dans les capitales
européennes cette semaine de l'Ukraine
donc on est on est plus qu'un allié de
l'Ukraine c'est-à-dire que d'ores et
déjà on a déjà fourni des munitions on a
fourni des missiles de courte portée les
Allemands vont fournir des chars dans
pas si longtemps que ça les Américains
sont dessus l'Europe a dépensé 50
milliards d'euros de aujourd'hui déjà
pour soutenir l'Ukraine les États-Unis
ont dépassé deux fois 50 milliards
il a formidablement bien dit je trouve
parce qu'il a quand même une façon
incroyable d'embarquer les gens il faut
quand même vraiment lui tirer le chapeau
pour ça c'est que il embarque tout
l'Occident derrière lui c'est ça
l'histoire qui est en train de se jouer
c'est à dire que il y a la Russie d'un
côté certes comme à dire Roselyne qui
essaie de réarmer de produire de
retrouver des nouvelles troupes parce
qu'ils sont assez exangs pour l'instant
et il y a pas eu la Persé ukrainienne
aussi rapide que prévu mais là c'est
tout l'Occident c'est c'est la France
c'est l'Angleterre c'est l'Allemagne
c'est les États-Unis surtout en premier
qui sont là et qui sont derrière
l'Ukraine jusqu'au bout juste la
question en deux secondes c'est comment
on va trouver une porte de sortie à
cette histoire en fait c'est ça la
question parce que c'est sans fin en
fait Jean-Luc est-ce que Vladimir
Poutine est aujourd'hui notre ennemi
nous Français nous Européens
oui oui
Vladimir Poutine est de fait notre notre
ennemi il est par le danger qu'il fait
courir à la paix mondiale
par le lancement d'une guerre sur le
territoire européen à nos portes et il
est par le discours qu'il a disant
lui-même que c'est une croisade contre
l'Occident contre notre valeur car on
est passé de l'Ukraine avec une question
au territoriale finalement assez
classique à vrai dire dans les conflits
mondiaux du 19e une guerre du 19e siècle
a une guerre idéologique parce que quand
on dit en fait le notre combat c'est
contre les homosexuels c'est contrôler
transgenres c'est contre la manière dont
on vit en Occident ces contrôles déclin
de l'Occident on est plus sur une
question classique territoriale pour
revenir à ce qui a été dit
c'est une situation très étrange parce
que nous sommes en guerre sans être
belligérant en fait
mais on est on est dans une
qui à propos des missiles il a dit il y
en avait deux qui avaient survolé des
des pays qui étaient membres de l'auto
alors ça ça a été démenti ensuite on va
juste mais oui on va écouter Emmanuel
Macron vous en parler aussi on va
écouter manuel Macron justement qui
répond à volodiumski justement sur cette
histoire des avions de combat écoutez-le
il était essentiel que les Alliés
privilégiés les matériels qui sont les
plus utiles par rapport
à l'effet final recherché par les
troupes de crayon et les plus rapides
dans aucun cas des avions de chasse ne
peuvent être livrés dans les semaines
qui viennent parce qu'il y a des délais
de formation de livraison et formation
incompressibles pour des avions qui ne
sont pas connus des pilotes
ukrainiens et donc je ne l'explique
absolument pas mais ça ne correspond pas
aujourd'hui aux besoins voilà pour le
moment Emmanuel Macron temporise mais il
est peut-être peut-être en train de
changer on va voir cette interview
accordée par Zelinski au Figaro on lui
demande s'il pense qu'Emmanuel Macron a
changé d'avis sur Vladimir Poutine le
président français qui avait l'année
dernière dit qu'il fallait qu'il ne
fallait pas humilier la Russie réponse
de zenos qui je crois qu'il a changé et
qu'il a changé pour de vrai cette fois
après tout c'est lui qui a ouvert la
porte livraison de char il a aussi
soutenu la candidature de l'Ukraine dans
l'Union européenne je crois que c'est un
vrai signal Claude qui Emmanuel Macron a
changé sur Vladimir Poutine
probablement
donc c'était une erreur de dire qu'il ne
fallait pas humilier la Russie
c'était probablement un propos prématuré
puisqu'il se plaçait d'ores et déjà dans
l'hypothèse d'un d'une sortie de guerre
en nous en sommes très très loin
la question elle a été évoquée par ma
voisine c'est comment est-ce que tout ça
se terminera il n'est pas acceptable
pour nous que l'Ukraine soit défaite
militairement et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes amenés à intensifier notre
soutien l'Ukraine et plus les combats
intensifs iront et plus l'agression
russe sera violente plus nous serons
amenés je dirais presque mécaniquement
accroître notre aide à l'Ukraine parce
que nous nous pouvons pas accepter que
l'Ukraine soit défaite c'est-à-dire que
Poutine atteignent son but de guerre qui
est de détruire un pays indépendant tout
tenté tout tenter au début du conflit
pour amener
Poutine à la raison parce que cette
histoire apparaît
évidemment
une époque où Macron a pensé pouvoir
dialoguer avec Poutine et il a pensé
accéder à la raison de Poutine et lui
démontrer et puis naturellement comme
ces démarches comme celle de des
Allemands et de tous ceux qui ont tenté
de circonvenir Poutine a été voué à
l'échec et donc on est face à une
situation d'un discours poutinien de
plus en plus de l'Iran qui désigne
l'Occident comme ennemi qui est dans
lequel on
se trouve amené évidemment
en Europe ce qui a changé c'est qu'il
était jamais venu déjà et qu'on l'a vu
physiquement et que ces images ont été
absolument incroyables mais pour
rebondir sur ce qui vient de disque qui
est compliqué aujourd'hui je crois le
plus compliqué c'est que la guerre
jusqu'où est-ce que la Crimée
mais soutien l'Ukraine mais est-ce que
si l'Ukraine va conquérir la Crimée qui
est une terre considérée comme russe par
les Russes les Russes dans ces cas-là
leur idéologie a fait leur ils vont dire
ben c'est le temps qui m'attaque donc
autant attaque la Russie donc comment on
va sortir
la question de jusqu'où on va et quels
sont les termes de la négociation
étaient posées
tout le temps où on a considéré que ça
pouvait se régler par la discussion on
voit bien aujourd'hui que l'emballement
russe fait que c'est pas la question de
savoir si on inclut la Crimée ou pas ça
ça viendra peut-être un jour mais dans
l'immédiat c'est d'éviter que l'Ukraine
soit défaite et donc de battre les
Russes sur sur le terrain
moi il m'arrive rarement de dire comme
ça Macron a raison mais là il a eu deux
fois raison il a eu raison de commencer
en essayant au début devant la
sidération générale d'essayer de parler
avec Poutine et garder un lien il a
raison aujourd'hui de constater qu'il
n'y a rien à tirer de cette de ces
discussions et si on peut me permettre
il y a quelque chose qui a changé aussi
c'est que au début on avait une guerre
on a aujourd'hui une campagne massive de
crime contre l'humanité c'est pas dans
la conscience européenne n'importe quoi
à ça ça rappelle des souvenirs qui sont
encore vives dans la conscience
collective de l'Europe et on ne peut pas
traiter ce conflit comme un conflit qui
aboutirait après à une négociation on se
dit voilà il y a peut-être un échange
peut-être un bout de tel endroit ou tel
endroit il y a un phénomène fondamental
c'est la campagne globale massive
cynique de crimes contre l'humanité qui
est mené par foutu les choses parce
qu'en effet maintenant c'est devenu
c'est devenu presque un combat éthique
c'est devenu un combat pour le pour le
droit c'est devenu un combat pour
l'humanité pour l'humanité parce que le
l'échec de l'accompagne russe sur
incapacité de d'obtenir le budget qu'ils
étaient fixés les a amenés à martyriser
la population
ukrainienne aujourd'hui la Russie ne
peut même pas dire que qui mène une
guerre conventionnelle il mène une
guerre qui torture qui qui humilie qui
vise à briser la résistance morale des
Ukrainiens en martyrisant les
populations ça évidemment c'est
totalement inacceptable et d'une
certaine façon c'est vrai qu'il y a une
spirale dans lequel Poutine nous
entraîne par ces méfaits en tout cas du
droit international la Crimée fait
partie de l'Ukraine et quand dans son
allocution dit à trois jours le
président français c'est vraiment à mi
c'est pas dans la déclaration de
volodies Zelinski devant la tribune des
Nations Unies enfin quand on pense que
Poutine et donc là dans le dans le
discours du président français en
sous-texte il y avait la Crimée
ukrainienne et quand on retourne
après on se dit qu'on a quand même
bonheur à pas être dans sa famille la
réforme des retraites est-elle en train
de se changer en match de boxe après les
mobilisations de cette semaine les
syndicats appellent à de nouvelles
journées d'action et pendant ce temps-là
à l'Assemblée nationale et ben on débat
du texte enfin on débat débat ou combat
regardez
n'ayons pas peur de
le matière de
route ou la faillite c'est ça la réalité
de notre système aujourd'hui que
faites-vous vous bloquez le pays vous
l'embourbez et tout ça pourquoi pour
économiser 0,1 point de PIB voilà votre
priorité vous êtes dérisoire je tiens à
dénoncer un fait extrêmement grave 4 ou
5 de nos députés femmes viennent de
recevoir un message leur indiquant que
Anne leurs enfants est à l'hôpital
hospitalisé il s'agit donc là d'une
manœuvre qui vise à empêcher ou à
distraire les députés du rassemblement
national de leur présence non
vous n'avez pas à frappé les pupitres la
parole est au gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous y sommes monsieur le ministre on va
suspendre 5 minutes le temps que c'est
un collègue laisse le gouvernement
s'exprimer bon Roselyne vous en avez vu
d'autres est-ce que c'est c'est un débat
habituel traditionnel quand on a des
réformes un peu sensibles
j'en ai subi quelques-uns là il y a
quand même de la part de strictement la
France insoumise il y a quand même une
hystérisation on a parlé de
bordélisation mais hystérisation du
débat terme de criaillerie de violence
on a vu on a vu du côté du gouvernement
l'image de ce député de la France
insoumise qui campe avec le la tête de
d'Olivier du soft sous les pieds etc il
y a une violence extraordinaire moi je
pense qu'il desservent là la cause
public on n'est pas dans la démocratie
je suis désolé lorsque aujourd'hui
madame seikiru traite la première
ministre de bourreau on n'est pas dans
la démocratie on est dans une tentative
de brutalisation du débat que je trouve
extraordinairement préoccupant vous
demandez ce que c'est le business à ce
jour non j'ai été journaliste
parlementaire pendant des années je n'ai
jamais vu ça ce niveau d'invective de
violence de mépris de disqualification
de l'adversaire venant en effet dans un
banc je suis désolé d'avoir à dire mais
veulent en effet d'un banc et hier soir
le le maître d'oeuvre de cette de de ce
de cette coalition qui se trouve à
l'extérieur le du sexe Akina de cette
machine
hier soir a donné le feu vert à aller
encore plus loin dans la brutalisation
on est dans un dans pour moi dans une
dans une stratégie qui salit la
démocratie je le dis très tranquillement
on est en train de salir le débat
démocratique en même temps et je ne
comprends même pas quel est l'objectif
parce que
je ne crois pas du tout qu'il fasse
avancer leur thèse par ses moyens là la
CFDT ça a été dit je parlais encore hier
avec un cas de la sfdt et dans un grand
malaise et le Parti socialiste est dans
un grand malaise parce qu'il y a une
extrémisation du combat où on a
l'impression qu'il faut à tout prix
rapporter le scalpes
gouvernement
qui va limiter le temps de débat dans
l'hémicyclasque il y a aussi une
responsabilité du côté du gouvernement
dans ce cette tension qu'on ressent dans
l'émission
la feuille patient en septembre ça a été
repoussé il y avait pas de possibilités
d'un débat serein de toute façon mais
pour renchérir sur ce que vient d'être
dit moi ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est
la stratégie suicidaire de la France
insoumise parce que je pense que ça
raisonnable je pense que ça exaspère
absolument tout le monde cette attitude
est y compris les gens qui sont dans
leur rang et qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils sont représentés de cette
façon là et ce qui est très embêtant
c'est que du coup le rassemblement
national qui aussi un papier un parti
extrémiste donne-lui l'impression d'une
plus grande responsabilité et
malheureusement il me semble que ceux
qui tireront les marrons du feu de cette
attitude c'est au contraire le
rassemblement national qui ne cesse de
parler de prise de responsabilité qui
débat sur le fond qui est beaucoup plus
calme etc et je c'est vraiment un grand
grand gâchis et en même temps je
voudrais juste rajouter quelque chose de
président de la République a été
interrogé hier lors d'un déplacement à
l'étranger sur comment la réforme des
retraites allait évoluer et il a répondu
et bien elle va se décider au Parlement
histoire de dire vous pouvez tous
manifester autant que vous voulez c'est
le Parlement il finit qui décidera mais
vous savez très bien donc la majorité
attend de voter avec LR que LR est pas
d'accord entre eux
on comprend même pas ce sondage et laby
général en fait il y a une vraie colère
aujourd'hui chez les Français
l'opposition à la réforme elle est
toujours très forte 65% des Français
disent non c'est le sondage et là de
cette semaine mais effectivement pour
une majorité d'entre eux 56%, les
députés doivent adopter une démarche de
compromis pour améliorer le projet du
gouvernement
de plus ils vont pas vous applaudir et
toutes les réformes depuis 20 ans qui
ont qui ont tout abouti en gros à la
jeter un an deux ans de cotise ou deux
ans à l'âge légal toutes les réformes
ont eu le même taux d'impopularité mais
jamais on a eu ce niveau d'hystérisation
parce que je me dis qu'il y a quand même
pas de réalité génétique qui ferait que
on aurait des reportages tous les jours
qui avec des Français qui nous disent
quel que soit le taux de pénibilité à 62
ans je ne peux plus travailler que ce
serait génétiquement possible pour un
Allemand travailler jusqu'à 67 ou un
danois de s'apprêter de faire jusqu'à 70
je vous dis ça un peu comme ça parce que
ça veut dire qu'on a une question sur la
valeur travail et sur la question du
travail dans notre société qui est une
question dont il faut débattre et
peut-être la qualité du travail est son
organisation notamment sur la sur la fin
de de carrière pour le reste oui le
spectacle est donné par et les filles
parce que c'est les filles en
l'occurrence à l'Assemblée
est assez pitoyable pourquoi d'abord
parce qu'il y a il y a un truc c'est que
atroce kyste c'est pas fabriqué pour
être dans une assemblée parlementaire
c'est honorable d'être ce qui se fait
ils sont pas fabriqués pour ça et comme
c'est ça qui donne vous avez raison ils
sont pas tous trop skis c'est quand même
l'idéologie dominante qui qui quand même
à imprégner dans la praxiste l'ensemble
de de ces gens donc c'est fait
pour être dans un assez fait pour être
dans une assemblée générale c'est fait
pour être dans un meeting c'est fait
pour être dans un soviet sans doute pas
sur une assemblée parlementaire
d'un pays démocratique et en même temps
ils ont le droit de parler
[Musique]
aboutir au fait qu'on n'aura pas discuté
à l'Assemblée nationale de l'article qui
intéresse les syndicats qui intéressent
les salariés c'est une stratégie absurde
en réalité est-ce que c'est
les filles n'existaient pas à
l'Assemblée nationale Macron les aurait
inventé une stratégie d'attention moi je
vois qu'une explication logique parce
que mais dans le champ est un être un
peu particulier mais globalement logique
je pense que 1 nous payons aujourd'hui
qui n'est pas été élu président de la
République c'était quand même pour lui
une humiliation qui n'a toujours pas
digéré qui n'est pas été élu premier
ministre ainsi qu'il avait sommet des
Français de le nommer et je pense nous
payons aussi l'erreur stratégique dont
il se reprend tous les jours qui est de
ne pas s'être présenté à la députation
je pense que au moment où il l'a fait ça
lui paraissait une habileté et
qu'aujourd'hui nous le payons cher
pourquoi parce que comme il est hors-jeu
il est d'une certaine façon amenée à
pour contrôler le jeu parlementaire
manipuler le groupe de la France
de manipuler le groupe de la France
insoumise d'une manière telle qu'il est
devenu quasiment ingable nous voyons à
l'oeuvre une génération de jeunes
députés qu'il faut bien appeler la
génération Mélenchon comme il y a une
génération Mitterrand qui ne sont pas du
tout pliées aux normes du respect et de
la dignité du travail parlementaire il
considère que tout est permis parce
qu'ils sont le camp du bien qu'en face
ils ont ils ont pu s'opposent à des
démons à des forces diaboliques et que
contre le Diable tous les coups sont
permis et bien non la démocratie se
sentait ce sont des codes ce sont des
règles ce sont des convenances ce sont
des attitudes qui peuvent être
hypocrites mais qui fait qu'on peut
continuer à se parler et si on ne se
parle plus dans une démocratie si on en
est à piétiner symboliquement une tête
tranchée on est on sort du champ
démocratique on va parler d'un autre
sujet avec cette question faut-il
supprimer le poste de Premier ministre
c'est notre troisième thème si je vous
pose la question c'est qu'on risque d'en
parler dans les mois qui viennent
puisque Emmanuel Macron on souhaite
réformer nos institutions un souhait
plusieurs fois avorté mais qui a été
remis au goût du jour cette semaine le
président a consulté mardi Nicolas
Sarkozy sur la question il a aussi reçu
à l'Elysée celui qui propose de faire du
chef de l'État le seul et unique maître
de l'exécutif toute la responsabilité
est mise sur la responsabilité du
président alors même que beaucoup de
décisions sont du niveau du Premier
ministre que l'administration est
concentrée au niveau du Premier ministre
ce qui explique quelquefois que y est
des malentendus entre président et
premier ministre ou des lourdeurs vous
passez qu'on lèverait c'est malentendus
si on supprimait le Premier ministre je
pense que aujourd'hui si on voulait que
l'exécutif soit beaucoup plus rapide
dans ces décisions beaucoup plus claires
dans sa communication beaucoup plus
coordonnée dans l'utilisation de ces
moyens oui je pense que l'exécutif doit
être unique moi je suis est-ce qu'il
faut supprimer le poste de Premier
ministre Jean-Luc alors boîte de fait
depuis très longtemps je suis convaincu
que oui
pas qu'il faut le supprimer mais je
pense que on a un système
je suis pour le supprimer je ne dis pas
que le système ne peut pas marcher mieux
avec toujours un premier ministre mais
je pense que c'est pas ça qui bloque le
système je pense que ça ne sert pas le
premier ministre se sert pas à
grand-chose dans nos institutions
d'ailleurs la preuve regardez comment se
fait comment on peut vivre trois mois
quasiment deux mois son premier ministre
parce que Emmanuel Macron hésite et
comment il y a une première ministre
nommée madame Vautrin presque nommé le
lundi et le mercredi quelqu'un d'autre
qui arrive donc voyez bien que c'est pas
c'est pas fondamental ça aide à une
chose c'est à faire la synthèse
majoritaire sur la base du rassemblement
du deuxième tour et cette fois-ci ça n'a
pas été le cas ça a été le cas avant
avec des premiers ministres qui étaient
le signe du rassemblement majoritaire
je vous donne la parole
de parce que vous m'aidez Jean-Luc a
lancé un duel parce que on m'a posé une
question et deux invités ne sont pas
d'accord à cette question est-ce le bon
moment de lancer un chantier d'une
réforme des institutions des invités je
vous le disais sont pas d'accord d'un
côté on a Roselyne de l'autre on a
Claude Rosine vous allez commencer vous
allez me dire pourquoi selon vous oui
c'est le bon timing c'est le bon moment
de lancer cette réforme des institutions
alors on se rend compte qu'il y a un
certain nombre de blocages ou de
dysfonctionnement dans les institutions
discuter alors du fond de ce qu'il faut
faire mais en tout cas si on fait ce
diagnostic qu'il y a des choses à
changer c'est le bon moment c'est le bon
moment pourquoi parce que si on est si
un président est un possibilité de se
représenter on va tout de suite accuser
de manipuler les choses à son propre
profit là le président ne peut plus
représenter et on est assez loin
d'élection présidentielle pour que cette
réforme des institutions ne vienne pas
polluer l'élection présidentielle à
venir donc ensuite on peut discuter du
le contenu des réformes à mener mais
c'est vraiment si on est convaincu de
ces réformes c'est vraiment le bon
moment pour les monnaies
[Musique]
bravo vous avez respecté votre temps
c'est super et vous n'êtes pas du tout
convaincu pardon
faire évoluer en fait il y a deux façons
de faire soit en vrai présidentialisme
l'ultra présidentialisme c'est-à-dire en
supprimant le Premier ministre soit au
contraire on fait un retour vers le
parlementarisme qui est ce que proposait
la France insoumise je pense que dans
les deux cas ça supposerait un consensus
minimal sur le fonctionnement des
institutions qui n'est pas du tout
atteint et qui n'a aucune chance d'être
atteint à échéance prévisible parce que
de toute façon vous ne mettez pas
d'accord les grandes forces politiques
ni ne nous mettrez pas d'accord
l'Assemblée le Sénat de toute façon
cette saison qui sont très mal foutues
qui sont bricolés ont montré une
extraordinaire capacité de d'adaptation
aux circonstances si le président gagné
gustative il allait plein pouvoir s'il
perd les législatives le pouvoir
traverse la scène d'une certaine façon
ça n'a pas si mal fonctionné le problème
que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est celui
de l'ultra présidentialisme c'est-à-dire
de la cristallisation de tous les autres
de tous les mécontentement sur une
personne supprimer le poste Premier
ministre ne ferait qu'aggraver cet état
de fait vous allez nous transférer tout
ça pas Valérie mais d'abord je vais vous
montrer les pistes qui sont envisagées
par Emmanuel Macron pour une réforme des
institutions il envisage il envisageait
un
retours
renouvelable la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires ou encore des élections
législatives de mi-mandat Valérie est-ce
que ces mesures vous paraissent
intéressantes ce sont des mesures de
circonstances pour essayer de résoudre
toute la cacophonie ambiante dont on a
beaucoup parlé je voudrais revenir sur
cette histoire Premier ministre je
trouve ça intéressant parce que sur le
papier je trouve que vous avez raison
Jean-Luc de dire le président peut très
bien faire et finalement il passe leur
temps à chamailler les deux et à
s'annuler un petit peu c'est peut-être
pas forcément très utile mais je suis
quand même impressionnée par le boulot
que fait Elisabeth borne parce que
imaginez que on est en ce moment un
président de la République en toute
première ligne toute la journée
à défendre face à la cacophonie ambiante
à l'Assemblée nationale et que en même
temps il doit accueillir j'ailinski et
gérer la guerre en Ukraine et qu'en même
temps il doit faire tout ce que je pense
que ça serait extrêmement compliqué pour
lui donc est-ce que il faudrait un
secrétaire général à l'Élysée
à défendre le président quoi
collaborateurs
moi sincèrement c'est quelqu'un que je
respecte beaucoup je trouve qu'elle
travaille extrêmement bien elle a
préparé cette réforme elle a mis les
gens d'accord si ça
je parle du gouvernement je parle pas
des gens dans la rue là je parle de du
gouvernement sur les elle joue elle est
en train de jouer son poste là sur les
têtes elle porte elle porte cette
réforme des retraites et c'est elle
quand même que tu allais voir Éric
Ciotti une fois qu'il a été élu en
disant bon Éric sotti qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez est-ce qu'on peut trouver un
accord est-ce qu'on peut éviter le 49-3
est-ce qu'on peut avoir une vie
démocratique ensemble etc et je pense
pas du tout que ce soit le rôle d'un
président de la République c'est
vraiment le rôle du Premier ministre
mais elle le porte très très bien ce
rôle en fait mon du président de la
République ordi ça peut paraître
un exemple qui s'appelle les États-Unis
d'Amérique où il y a un président
extraordinairement fort et un parlement
américain
[Musique]
S
et sur la politique américaine a très
très peu de pouvoir beaucoup moins de
bruit blanc
on va reparler on va reparler des
États-Unis Macron non plus y arrive pas
Jean-Luc faudrait juste dire une phrase
en réponse à ce que vous avez dit c'est
la force de l'administration américaine
qu'on a pas en France non mais c'est ça
il y a d'autres c'est la force
d'administration américaine et c'est le
fait c'est le spoiling system c'est à
dire que quand le nouveau président
arrive il arrive avec ces hommes il
change tout le monde et il met en place
une force de frappe
voisine lève la main rosé lève la main
vous voulez instaurer la pétaudière on a
déjà la pétaudière voulait installer la
paralysie absolue faites des
législatives ami mandat vous êtes sûr
que le président perdra législatives et
que le pays sera un gouverte
que je peux dire parce que je suis la
somme ici
donc l'état explique bien sûr que le
premier ministre est absolument
indispensable parce que finalement on a
de la gestion d'un état que l'écume dont
on parle au jour le jour mais c'est pas
ça du tout c'est qu'on gère des multi
multitude de problèmes et que finalement
à Matignon il y a un train on gère un
train qui déraille toutes les 15 minutes
et que il faut absolument un premier
ministre pour gérer une équipe
gouvernementale moi ce dont je rêve et
dont j'ai eu le sentiment qui était
utile c'est pas dans l'organisation du
gouvernement ne plus avoir de Premier
ministre c'est que le Président de la
République soit dans son rôle et que le
Conseil des Ministres se déroule sans le
président de la République avec un
Premier ministre qui est là à la tête de
son équipe mais je nommé bien sûr mais
je fais pardon mais c'est une sorte de
pas de caricature mais d'extrême de dire
comment comment fonctionne un état que
le président est trop de pouvoir se dép
voilà de déplacer par exemple les
préfets parce qu'ils sont actuellement
chez le ministre de l'Intérieur chez le
ministre de l'intérieur ce qui est
absurde il faut qu'il soit auprès du
Premier ministre ça date de l'époque où
les préfets n'avaient qu'un rôle de
sécurité publique alors qu'ils sont
maintenant les coordinateurs de toute
l'administration de l'État de réfléchir
à ça de réfléchir comment fonctionne une
équipe une équipe gouvernementale avec
des ministres chefs de Paul avec
vraiment un resserrement de l'équipe
gouvernementale et d'avoir une équipe
opérationnelle alors ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas de contact entre le
Président de la République dans son rôle
et le Premier ministre mais franchement
supprimer le Premier ministre
très très rapidement petite ouais mais
on peut parler des États-Unis
parce que moi j'ai vu aussi comment
pourquoi est-ce que les ministres sont
aussi faibles en ce moment pourquoi
parce que c'est ça le sujet aussi non
mais heureusement qu'on a une première
ministre quand même parce que les
premiers miniers les ministres il y
avait une époque on est à quelques
expériences autour de cette table 62 ans
c'est un cercle vicieux et on a plus on
a plus ça on a appelé nous avons compris
le général vous a compris les amis on va
avancer parce que vous vouliez parler
des États-Unis
cette semaine devant le Congrès le
président américain a prononcé le
traditionnel discours sur l'état l'Union
sorte de programme pour l'année à venir
le discours de Biden a duré un peu plus
d'une heure et avait parfois des accents
de campagne électorales
il y a deux ans le covid a fermé nos
commerces nos écoles et nous a priver de
tant de choses aujourd'hui le covid ne
contrôle plus nos vies il y a deux ans
notre démocratie a fait face à sa plus
grande menace depuis la guerre civile et
aujourd'hui bien que meurtri notre
démocratie reste préservée et un violet
Valérie les Américains peuvent dire
merci à Joe après deux ans
l'Amérique de Trump personnellement
sincèrement l'inflation
montait beaucoup mais elle est en train
de redescendre ils sont dans un a plein
d'emploi ils ont 3,2% de chômeurs je
sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
c'est absolument historique c'est jamais
arrivé alors on va le regarder les
chiffres de l'économie américaine les
États-Unis qui connaissent leur leur
plus faible taux de chômage depuis 50
ans vous l'avez dit 3,5 % et l'inflation
qui est en train de refluer on a les
prix ont baissé sur les derniers mois de
l'année ils ont mis en place pour une
fois un système qui ressemble un petit
peu à la sécurité sociale même si c'est
pas la sécurité sociale mais où les plus
démunis peuvent se soigner et tous en
discours de l'Union a été tourné
justement vers cette vers les plus
démunis on en parle pas souvent aux
États-Unis un des pauvres des démunis de
cetera on parle beaucoup d'argent de
réussite et d'ailleurs c'est incroyable
parce que Biden il a été beaucoup plus
audacieux que Emmanuel Macron en France
et il a il a dit il faut que les grandes
multinationales les Google les Facebook
les machins etc il faut qu'il paye des
impôts il faut qu'il participe à les
formations etc et je trouve que
globalement
je trouve que globalement c'est un
discours qui a du sens alors
laquelle les Américains n'aiment pas et
on le comprend c'est qu'il a déjà eu 80
ans que l'élection est dans deux ans et
que s'il représente on va parler de ça
[Musique]
il y a quand même ce paradoxe vous
l'évoquez le son avec ce sondage qu'on
va avoir du Washington Washington pose
je vais arriver de la chaîne ABC 62 %
des Américains estiment que Joe Biden
n'a pas fait grand chose voir rien ou
presque depuis son élection comment vous
expliquer ce paradoxe Claude je
l'explique très facilement le les
Américains comme comme les Français
surestiment les pouvoirs du président
des États-Unis et nous-mêmes nous
pensons que le président des États-Unis
parce qu'il est le président de l'état
le plus puissant au monde et l'homme le
plus puissant du monde j'ai lu les
mémoires de pouvoir qui sont presque
aussi intéressants que ce rôle de rosée
de Barack Obama et j'ai lu la semaine
dernière le livre d'entretien qu'il a eu
avec Bruce Springsteen qui est très
intéressant aussi et en réalité on se
rend compte que c'est Gulliver empêché
le président des États-Unis comme le
président de la République française
passe son temps à rêver d'un monde idéal
qui n'arrive pas à fabriquer la réforme
de la Sécurité sociale qu'il a essayé
d'instaurer vous souvenez Kobama il y a
après ces deux mandats et il en est
sorti une souris quand même de la de son
grand plan social il en est sorti une
souris l'Amérique est
presque toujours le président a contre
lui un sénat d'opposition presque
toujours il a contre lui une grande
partie des médias et presque toujours il
a une fois sur deux il a contre lui la
Chambre des Représentants et il a un
système fédéral qui fait que le
gouvernement central a très très peu
d'influence dans la réalité de la vie
quotidienne des habitants d'une
ébrasserole de la Californie donc et on
a le même phénomène en France de lot de
high expectation Anne la Resort c'est à
dire que chaque élection on a
l'impression que c'est une espèce
d'ardoise magique ou un candidat arrive
et promet et puis au pouvoir forcément
les c'est Churchill qui disait le la
politique est un métier impossible parce
qu'on est condamné à échoué oui par
rapport aux attentes des Français des
Américains un président atteindra jamais
que 50% au mieux des objectifs qu'ils
étaient Jean-Luc il est en positif selon
vous de Joe Biden 2 ans après son
élection
oui c'est un bilan qu'on adorerait avoir
chez nous comme quoi mais c'est vrai par
rapport aux ambitions c'est toujours
difficile un président sans Premier
ministre comme un président avec Premier
ministre parce que sur la difficulté de
faire les réformes ou d'engager des
modifications structurelles les deux
sont en panne de la même façon de
manière de manière manifeste sur le
discours de Biden moi ce qui m'a frappé
mais c'est d'abord c'était un jour avec
énergie
il était jeune binden là en tout cas il
était moins vieux que dans certains
discours on avait du mal oui c'est un
discours important c'est un discours
institutionnel deuxièmement c'était un
discours oui c'est un discours de
campagne parce qu'il y avait tout un
bilan mais surtout parce qu'il y avait
dans les mots jusqu'à l'utilisation des
mots les invisibles pour parler des plus
pauvres etc de comment dire de conjurer
ce qui a fait l'échec des démocrates
dans la dernière dans les dernières
périodes et en particulier
d'Hillary Clinton c'est d'avoir négligé
droite à gauche Joe Biden oui c'est un
président centriste disons centriste
parce que la notion de gauche est droite
aux États-Unis par rapport à la France a
pas tout à fait le même sens pour
l'instant ce sont des choses qui sont
sur les rails en lancement qui sont pas
encore opérationnels toutes ces idées
que ce soit
l'inflation réduction Act ou le chips
sur les sur les semis conducteurs va
bien voir ce que ça donnait enfin les
résultats par pour l'instant les
résultats de Joe Biden c'est c'est
l'économie américaine ça marche on
connaît c'est une économie qui est
évidemment super puissante et
impérialiste je sais pas si c'est à
cause de byden ou je crois que vous
pensez que
ces résultats pour l'instant et moi ce
qui est effectivement il a été assez
tonique par rapport au discours qu'il
avait tenu dans les mois précédents il a
été dopé à je ne sais quoi en tout cas
finissons le boulot c'était la phrase
l'ancienne répéter de façon récurrente
finissons le boulot
un discours tonique oui mais quand même
on voyait qu'il a chopé très souvent sur
les mots de son discours il y avait
quand même un manque de fluidité verbale
qui est la caractéristique de Biden et
qui nous rappelait à chaque moment son
âge heureusement
par la le très mauvais état de la droite
américaine qui est très divisée donc
tout est possible
4% de taux de popularité ça ferait
rêvait en France
il aura 92 ans en 2024 planter des
graines à la perspective d'une nouvelle
candidature qui paraissait au départ
improbable jusqu'à
une hypothèse plus puisque sérieuse à
gauche oui clairement avec une intention
particulière sur la question du racisme
sur la question de l'égalité des femmes
sur la question des droits des
homosexuels sur tous ces critères là par
rapport à notre pattern intellectuel
européen il est clairement de gauche
mais il a aussi lancé inoffensive en
direction des classes moyennes parce que
si il se présente c'est dans la
reconquête des classes moyennes qui peut
infliger une défaite à celui qu'il s'est
au faux choisi déjà comme adversaire qui
est Donald Trump le cauchemar d'une
grande partie des Américains tous les
amis que j'ai eu au téléphone c'est de
rejouer le match Biden Trump et il est
bien possible que ça soit comme ça que
ça se termine la crise que traverse nos
amis britanniques est-elle due au brexit
trois ans après la sortie du Royaume-Uni
de l'Union européenne le pays traverse
une crise inédite des grèves massives
tout je touche tous les secteurs de
l'économie lundi le système de santé
publique a connu la plus importante
journée de grève de son histoire écoutez
il s'agit simplement d'infirmiers et
d'aide-soignant normaux et ordinaire qui
n'ont plus les moyens de faire le
travail qu'ils aiment
ils ne peuvent pas s'occuper de leur
passion en toute sécurité c'est ce qui
les oblige à faire cela et c'est la
seule façon semble-t-il d'obtenir que le
gouvernement en tienne compte
nous sommes ici pour être entendus oui
nous sommes ici pour être
il est grand temps que le gouvernement
commence à écouter le plaidoyer des
infirmières à propos de salaires il
coûte la vie des patients et cause
beaucoup de ravages dans notre système
de santé
on va voir les chiffres de l'inflation
au Royaume-Uni 10,5% sur un an avec une
possible récession dans les mois à venir
on est entre 5 et 6% en France à titre
de comparaison en termes d'inflation
c'est dû au brexit tout ça la crise à
laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui au
Royaume-Uni écoutez ils ont pas eu de
chance parce que le brexit est arrivé au
moment où il y avait la crise pour moi
c'est le cumul des deux c'est à dire que
la crise qu'on vit en France à cause de
l'Ukraine de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie etc bien évidemment que ils
ont subissent aussi les contrecoups mais
ils ont un effet beaucoup plus important
en raison de leur isolement l'autre jour
j'écoutais Bruno Le Maire et ça m'a
vraiment intéressé parce qu'il parlait
de la crise des vaccins et pendant la
crise des vaccins on se souvient pas
pendant le covid on a mutualisé les
dettes en Europe pour la première fois
l'Allemagne a accepté de mutualiser les
dettes c'était jamais arrivé avant et
bien les Anglais ils ne bénéficieront
plus de ça c'est à dire qu'ils sont
d'une vulnérabilité aujourd'hui ils sont
tout seuls et le brexit c'est transport
s'est transformé en vrai regret ou je
sais pas comment il appelle ça oui
ils ont pris conscience malheureusement
mais c'est trop tard que aujourd'hui ils
sont tous seuls et ils sont c'est le
seul pays nous on est en croissance de 2
et demi pour cent je crois eux ils sont
à moins 0,5
si vous voulez des difficultés que tout
le monde connaît parce qu'ils n'ont plus
personne sur qui s'appuyait ils peuvent
plus combattants ni pour leur monnaie ni
pour leur dette ni pour rien du tout et
c'est la fin du brexit alors est-ce
qu'on a été trop ferme nous européens
nous Français avec le Royaume-Uni au
moment du brexit je la poser
ultra violence c'est étrange de dire
quoi c'est ceux qui sont restés dans
l'appartement qui étaient violents mais
admettons non évidemment non les crises
elles viennent rarement d'une raison
unique donc il y a plein de raisons qui
font la difficulté que connaissent les
Britanniques aujourd'hui le brexit en
est forcément une d'autant que la
promesse de Boris Johnson en réalité qui
était on s'en moque il y a la mairie
parce que l'administration américaine
n'est pas aussi encline que Boris
Johnson l'avait dit à sa population à
venir en support et en soutien de
l'économie de l'économie de l'économie
britannique donc oui évidemment que ça
ça joue à en regardant ces images et en
regardant les manifestations et les
témoignages je me disais quand même que
quand on regarde l'immense violence
sociale quand même qui qui règne en
Grande-Bretagne qui a souvent régné
c'est un pays très dur de ce point de
vue là ceux qui a l'Assemblée nationale
en France trade de de bourreau Macron de
massacreurs ça serait bien qu'il qui que
le refaire un week-end à Londres alors
on a posé la question britannique savoir
si regrettait finalement ce brexit on va
voir cette enquête publiée par le
journal zineda pendent 54% des
Britanniques jugent que la sortie de
l'Union européenne était une mauvaise
décision il n'était que 46 % l'année
dernière 75 65 % d'entre eux
réclameraient même un nouveau scrutin
pour revenir sur le brexit donc ça
malgré le fait pour moi les difficultés
britanniques c'est vraiment le brexit
sur fond évidemment d'une crise qui
touche qui a touché toute l'Europe en
particulier on peut dire que tout le
monde reprend reprend ses billes que
finalement on en revient là maintenant à
peu près dans tous les pays à la
situation 2019 sauf au Royaume-Uni donc
qu'est-ce qui fait la différence entre
ces pays entre le pays entre le
Royaume-Uni et nous c'est vraiment le
brexit et le brexit qui a été causé par
conséquences d'une classe politique
britannique et en particulier du Parti
conservateur qui s'est vraiment conduit
d'une manière absolument impossible et
de façon récurrente et je dirais
déterminer dans l'erreur donc bien sûr
alors sur un pays qui est très isolé et
voilà et je trouve que quand même encore
46% des anglais quand sur le proposition
pareil
la position travail
en démocratie le peuple a toujours
raison il est d'autant plus déplorable
qu'il se trompent si souvent les peuples
peuvent se tromper collectivement le
peuple britannique même une erreur donc
pour des raisons qui ont été mille fois
analysées j'ai pas les reprendre ici il
y avait évidemment la peur de la
concurrence du plombier polonais il y
avait le vieux ressentiment allergar du
continent qui fait partie culturellement
génétiquement de la culture britannique
il y avait parce qu'on lui a beaucoup
menti aussi il y avait cette inconscient
impérial qui reste tellement fort en
Grande-Bretagne idée le monde est à nous
nous sommes une impériale on n'a pas
besoin on n'a pas besoin des
continentsaux et d'une certaine façon la
Grande-Bretagne se projetait dans un
monde qui n'existe plus parce que toutes
les démocraties occidentales sont
malmenées par la mondialisation le
l'épaule le l'équilibre du monde a
basculé vers le Pacifique c'est un
enfant de 4 ans c'est ça mais je crois
que les Anglais ne l'avaient pas
totalement réalisé est-ce que c'est
possible de revenir en arrière
aujourd'hui l'Union européenne et le
royaume des gens en Grande-Bretagne qui
envisagent même de recourir
ce qu'il en pense parce qu'il a quand
même négocier il a quand même essayé
d'empêcher tout ça pendant la réponse
pendant plusieurs années la réponse
la réponse à votre question tiens un
chiffre de tous les pays du G7 un seul
l'an dernier a eu une récession
économique sur les 7 pays de cette un
seul c'est la Grande-Bretagne il n'a pas
deux c'est un peu que ce soit
envisageable d'abord ça il négociation
prendront
sans doute
peut-être aussi pour l'Union européenne
autour de ça mais je ne vois pas
l'intérêt de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui ah ben non c'est à dire
qu'en réalité le déficit pour l'Union
européenne est très faible il est très
faible il pose il a posé des quelques
minutes avec la pêche je dis pas qu'elle
est mieux mais en tout cas des papas
plus mal elle est pas dans cette
situation difficile et entre nous soit
dit quand il a été question de
mutualiser les dettes etc heureusement
qu'on a pas eu à discuter avec vous vous
souvenez l'équivalent madame tchecher
qui
est bien de la réponse de Jacques Chirac
à ce moment-là que j'ai paruré
sur un plateau voilà
n'hésiterai pas
embêtant c'est la défense
nucléaire mais c'est quand même tous les
accords entre la France et l'autre
partie du paquet de l'institutionnel
européen enfin on est tellement solide
on est tellement oui mais l'Allemagne
avec l'OTAN alors que la France
souhaiterait réarmer avec l'Europe et on
est très isolés dans notre dans notre
position et les accords de Lancaster
tout ça on est très proche des
Britanniques sur la partie défense quoi
comme chaque semaine on va terminer
l'émission par un top flop la question
vous la connaissez qui a marqué
l'actualité en bien ou en match Jean-Luc
vous commencez vous avez un toc et un
flop mais c'est la même personne je
crois j'ai un top c'est Mélenchon ça
m'arrive rarement émission de télévision
et des propos je trouve assez sensé sur
l'idée qu'en République il y a pas de
péché éternel il y a pas de peine qui
une fois que il y a eu condamnation et
qu'elle est assurée vous empêche
d'exister ce droit à la rédemption il
l'a fait sur sur Adrien catenas et je
trouvais qu'il y avait des formules sur
la manière de se comporter face à une
condamnation qui était assez
intelligente et le fleuve c'est le même
Mélenchon dans la même émission qui
s'est sentie obligée d'aller insulter
les journalistes
charognard malhonnête voilà au point qui
quitte l'émission à un moment donné et
ça lui coûtait pas grand chose
écoutez pas grand chose il venait de
faire une heure et demie où il avait
fait une émission donc il est parti au
début ça peut être courageux à la fin
c'est jamais que du cinéma et cette
espèce de de violence comme si il
accusait les journalistes il l'a dit
d'ailleurs de leur poser une question
qui est une question évidente
d'actualité sur le retour de cadenas à
l'Assemblée
et surtout comme s'il était malheureux
d'avoir pu répondre intelligemment à une
question qui lui était posée en
reprochant qu'on lui ai posé c'est
raisonnable tant terrifiant et habituel
de Mélenchon
c'est saluer la mémoire de Daniel defer
le fondateur de Ed en France
compagnon de Michel Foucault sociologue
séduit vraiment qui a été à l'origine de
ce mouvement des malades et du fait que
le malade n'était pas un sujet passif
mais bien actif dans le domaine de la
santé et le deuxième le deuxième top
c'est le rapprochement de Gustavo du
Damel qui était au philharmonique de Los
Angeles et qui est maintenant à New York
puisqu'il est en même temps qu'aux
directeur il est directeur musical de
l'opéra de Paris et c'est l'homme
directement
issu de ce qu'on appelle de elle Systema
c'est à dire de la démocratisation de la
culture de la dém de la démocratisation
par la culture et par la musique et je
veux saluer Gustavo dit d'Avel Valérie
votre top et votre flop le top c'est le
pape qui a dit qu'il fallait arrêter
d'incriminer les homosexuels c'est pas
la phrase exacte mais à peu près et je
pense que c'est important parce que
c'est la liberté des homosexuels de
retourner à l'église et d'être accueilli
par l'Église et je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup d'homosexuels qui peuvent être
malheureux de se sentir exclu de cette
façon là et le pape François en tant que
tel peut les aider à changer en partie
cette espèce de malaise qui avait chez
eux et je salue le pape François pour
beaucoup
et la deuxième donc le flop c'est que le
gouvernement alors
ça me semble absolument hallucinant
c'est à dire que le gouvernement a
décidé de repousser l'obligation du
service national universel qui est comme
vous savez
l'obligation enfin le fait que tous les
jeunes dans ce pays fassent un service
national universel pourquoi pour créer
de la cohésion pour vivre ensemble pour
apprendre des choses sous prétexte que
ils auraient peur que la jeunesse
s'enflamme avec la réforme des retraites
donc là au marché sur la tête et surtout
on repousse quelque chose qui est très
important et qui fait pas repousserait
rapidement notre top of
ça fait le lien on aurait pu les envoyer
en Turquie parce que quitte apparaît de
bisounours qui t'a parlé de Bisounours
ou mon top c'est que j'ai été
impressionné par la rapidité la
l'efficacité de la mobilisation
internationale qui s'est mise en marche
notamment en Europe pour aider pour
aider la Turquie quoi que nous ayons
n'ayons par ailleurs à l'égard du régime
turc qui d'ailleurs va payer
probablement un groupe très cher pour sa
mauvaise gestion j'aimerais bien ce
genre de tragédie et le flop c'est tout
simple c'est c'est une réjouissance moi
j'avoue que je me réjouis que cnews ou
Hanouna ou je sais pas qui va payer soit
lourdement condamné pour pour son
comportement de malotrus sur son plateau
à l'égard d'un député d'Empire je ne
partage aucun aucune prise de position
mais en effet je pense cette émission
dégrade l'audiovisuel public dégrade des
bas démocratique et le l'ironie de la
faire c'est que c'est pour avoir un
député qui par ailleurs d'un insulteur
professionnel
que vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous suivre à nous suivre et à nous
revoir en replay et en podcast Merci à
VOUS excellent weekend à tous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même jour
même heure même endroit bye bye
[Musique]